our firefighters going to go on strike
do you think good morning well we're in
the middle of a ballot as you say it's a
secret ballots I won't know the results
of that till the end of January but all
the indications are there's a huge
amount of anger out there among our
members that's this isn't just this year
this is 12 years of stagnating pay
driven by central government
unfortunately but also by fire service
employers and Fire Chiefs and we keep
being told to tighten our belts like
workers across the country and
firefighters are telling us they've had
enough they are struggling to pay the
bills and that's why we've ended up in
this situation with us balloting
unfortunately for industrial action
people are not prepared to take this any
longer and they're telling us they want
to fight back is it responsible for a
key emergency service to go on strike
well of course nobody wants to go on
strike nobody joins the fire service to
go on strike but at the end of the day
people have to pay the bills and uh it
comes to Breaking Point and uh we have
people as you've reported in in some
cases even using food banks reported by
their own employers that that's
happening uh it's acknowledged that pay
has fallen significantly year after year
real wages falling and eventually people
have to look after their families and
the government needs to step in put
money into public services including the
fire service to provide decent funding
for decent pay to stop living standards
falling I was just looking at the the
figures once fully qualified
firefighters basic salary in London will
increase to 38 340 to 39
325 pounds per annum the average salary
is that right the average salary in the
UK 38 600. just just you you need to
compare apples with apples it's the
basics of a statistical honesty you're
using you're conflating London figures
with national figures the national
figure for a competent firefighter is 32
000 pounds a year that's the salary of a
competent firefighter after several
years of training so you're using
incorrect figures so coaching the London
figures uh 39 325 in that case in that
case you would need to compare the
London figure with the London wage
wouldn't you rather than completely so
there's not a lot of difference
let me finish let me finish you've asked
a question you've asked a question if
you're going to compare a London salary
of a firefighter you need to compare it
with the London salary of an average
which work and that's not what you're
doing you're twisting the facts get your
facts right if you're going to ask
questions
okay you tell me what the figures are
then because the figures on your website
say that this is this is from your
website it says 39 325 pounds is what a
qualified fast Fighters basically it's
not open from our website the competent
firefighters wage in the UK is 32
244 pounds so I don't know where you've
got your figures from okay well let's
talk about what the government says
because the government says that if they
give a double-digit pay rise it's going
to fuel inflation even further and that
is going to make the cost of living
Christ last even longer well this is
just nonsense because there is no
evidence that the pay of public sector
workers has caused inflation whatsoever
so instead of Simply repeating
government spin to people you should
look at the facts the inflation has been
caused by factors far outside our
control our members as other workers
have had to be told for more than a
decade to tighten their belts while the
richest people in this Society get
richer and richer corporations make
bigger and bigger profits the government
just a few weeks ago was willing to hand
out 45 billion pounds in tax cuts to the
wealthiest in society but sell working
people that they need to tighten their
belts and their families just have to
make do that's simply not acceptable and
millions of people across the country
are saying is not acceptable that's what
lies behind our disputes and the other
disputes that you're seeing across the
country yeah I talk about those disputes
the General Secretary of the pcsu says
it's a matter of time before we see
synchronized strikes is that something
you'd support
well if people are facing a common uh
attack which is on their living
standards why would they not work
together to try and force that attack
back so yes we will talk to other unions
we're in a dispute for ourselves which
is about firefighters pay with our
employers and the funding necessary for
the government to uh to to resolve that
but other workers are in a very similar
position and yes of course workers talk
to each other and trade unions talk to
each other it's simply common sense
is it not a fear though that you'll lose
public support if we have a situation
that is essentially a general strike
won't the public get get seriously fed
up well I think the experience we've got
is that millions of ordinary people
across the country are sick and tired of
the richest people in society we're
given uh dodgy contracts during covid
tax cuts and seeing the profits of big
corporations boosted year after year
after year while Ordinary People are
told there is no money for them it's
simply a ludicrous during the pandemic
our members and others were called covid
Heroes they were clapped by the prime
minister they kept essential Services
going and as soon as that crisis begins
to ease we're told there's no money for
any rewards and that people need to take
further pay cuts how long should people
carry on taking pay cuts is simply
nonsense and it's not acceptable
okay uh we must leave you there the
results of that ballot Matt you did say
end of January was it 30th of January
yeah okay we'll find out more uh then uh
for now Matt rack from the fbu thank you
very much thank you